to actually win that overall majority if
you treated voters with the intelligence
they haven't and answer their questions
in terms of what what if so what might
happen if there was a coalition that
needed treat people with with their
entire I I think that it's fair in the
last seven days to do everything you can
to try and win I want to use the limited
time I've got including the 28 minutes
tonight to explain why a conservative
majority government will be good for
Britain I think we'd go further and
faster in clearing the deficit in
building those homes in providing those
pensions that's what I want to do and
again your trendy but if they let me
make this point that people know with me
if we fall short I will do the right
thing for the country I did last time I
would again but I i would still plead
with people with seven days to go
particularly when you're faced with the
alternative of Labor government back by
the SNP people who don't even want our
country to succeed or even exist when
that's the alternative put your trust in
23 more seats for the Conservatives and
we can have a very strong and very clear
government David Cameron thank you very
much